Ryan, good to see you again, my friend.
How are you? Are you in a volcano? Do
you have help on the way?
Now, Ryan Gosling's response here might
seem random, but hear me out. He's
actually using a technique that you can
use to turn any dull conversation into
an incredibly memorable one.
But, in order to get there, we need to
talk about the problem first. And that
is that conversations feel repetitive
for one primary reason, because we are
all stuck in the frame. Now, frames are
the unspoken rules that influence our
interactions, kind of like the templates
that we have to stick to.
>> [music]
>> For instance, if you're getting to know
someone, you'll usually start by asking
where they're from or what they do for
work, maybe. Now, the frame is there in
all of these situations for a reason. We
need some sort of understanding of how
we're going to interact, but the frame
can be restrictive, and it can lead you
second-guessing what you can and can't
say.
So, anytime you thought, "Can I say that
to my boss?" or "Should I ask that on a
first date?" you have found the edge of
the frame. Most people think that
terrible things will happen if they
break out of the expected frame. But the
surprising truth is you actually become
far, far more likable and charismatic if
you escape the frame. You can watch how
this interviewer does it. I got these
glasses in because these were from the
original Blade Runner. This is what they
used.
>> That's so cool that you did that.
Are you a fan of the original? Never
seen it.
>> [laughter]
>> Now, in a situation like this, most
people would be very embarrassed to
admit that they hadn't seen a classic
film in front of that lead actor. And
they might even bend the truth to try to
avoid that awkward moment. But this
interviewer gets an incredibly positive
reaction by breaking the frame. She sets
a playful tone for the rest of this
conversation. Did you get your knitting
needles out cuz I know you like to relax
with your
>> to go there. We're going to go with the
Oh, it's going to be like that. I looked
at your jumper. I just looked at your
jumper and I thought
>> [laughter]
>> This is what I did on set. I knitted
this sweater. So, when it's done in the
right way, escaping the frame can turn
very boring conversations into fun ones.
It'll make people love being around you.
>> [screaming]
>> Allison. So, how do you break out of
these frames? Well, the first thing you
can do is to follow the shiny thing. The
shiny thing is anything in the
environment that grabs your attention.
Ryan, good to see you again, my friend.
How are you? Are you in a volcano? I was
rushing back from a tour of the Grand
Canyon to do this interview and we broke
down on the side of the road. Most
people will notice the shiny thing in
conversation, but they don't mention it
because they see it as a distraction.
But, pretending the obvious thing
doesn't exist actually means that they
miss the opportunity to have a more fun
conversation. So, if you're in a Zoom
meeting, you see a cat walk back through
the background, or you see a colleague's
lock screen and it's got a picture of a
trip that they took, ask them about it.
Bring it up. It's going to make for a
far more interesting conversation, but
it's not the only way to break a frame.
You can also open the circle. You see,
many frames exclude other people. At a
job interview, people will tend to talk
to the interviewer, but they're very
short with the receptionist. They
completely ignore the other candidates.
At a coffee shop, people will place
their order with the barista, but they
often ignore the other people right next
to them in line. We're all sort of
pretending that these people in the same
room don't see one another. But, opening
the circle to include those people is
actually super charismatic. And you
know, the the best part of this, my
girlfriend is holding the phone. Can she
turn it around, please? Hi. Hi. Hi.
This is This is Iris. Hi, Iris. She's
holding the phone.
>> This is mine. You're you're MVP, Iris.
You see, in the interview frame, anyone
who's behind the camera, you're supposed
to pretend that they don't exist. But,
Ryan doesn't do this, and by including
Iris in the conversation, he gets a very
positive response. So, one easy way to
do something similar when you're not in
an interview is to bring people who are
around you in your scenarios in your
life in compliment.
You got some sweet moves, my friend.
Thank you, my brother.
Thank you.
So, look out for those people that you
tend to see every week, but you barely
interact with. This could be at someone
at work, but they're on a different
team, or the neighbor that you see when
you collect the mail, or the person that
is near you at the bar. It doesn't
doesn't matter. Just find a way to
acknowledge them instead of ignoring
them, and compliments are a great start.
Now, if you use these two frame breaks,
you're going to create way more fun
flowing conversations, but those alone
will not reliably make lasting
connections. This brings us to the third
point. You want to imply friendship
fast. So, ask yourself,
"What would I say if this person was a
close friend?" Watch how Ryan does it. I
definitely want to hear that you got out
of this.
I will reach out to the studio and let
you know.
I appreciate it.
>> Now, I'm not saying that you need to ask
the bartender to message you when they
get home, but treating people like you
are already friends is a great way to
connect with people. And one way you can
do this is to acknowledge other people's
emotions, as so many no space for those.
For example, if someone at work is
frustrated after a meeting, or it looks
like they're going through a hard time
at home, most people try to pretend they
don't see it, they don't address it,
they stick to that work frame. But if
you were to say something like, "Hey,
[music] seems like you might be going
through a hard time. Do you mind if I
ask how you're doing?" You'd actually be
amazed at how often people want to open
up about these things, and how your
relationships go deeper. [music]
Now, take a look at what using all three
of these frame breaks looks like in a
work environment, and watch [music] how
it makes everything more enjoyable. And
so, how can we make sure that they're
getting the right data now, so we don't
have this problem again? What's your
daughter called?
She's called Scarlett. Scarlett, I think
it looks better on the lower shelf.
>> [laughter]
>> And it's a lovely unicorn. It's a lovely
unicorn. Okay, so obviously What's his
name?
And do stop me if you need to crack on.
Do do tell us. I'm good. I'm good. Thank
you. What's his name? My name is
Christian.
His name is Christian. Christian. Yes.
Um
we're just deciding where it can go
where
nobody wants it to go. All right. Where
does Mommy want it to go? I think just
on that shelf is great. Thank you. I'm
so sorry.
This is the most informative interview
I've done all day. Um
When you do what this interviewer did
and what Ryan Gosling did, you
immediately become the charismatic
leader in any interaction because you're
the person who is acknowledging the
reality that everyone else pretends not
to see because of course we all notice
when someone's kid walks into a Zoom
meeting. Of course, we see that the wife
or the husband is standing there idly
while we're having a conversation with
their partner. And of course, we notice
that that coworker seems sad but is
holding it in. But almost no one will
take the leap and include those
impossible to ignore things
>> [music]
>> in actual conversation even though deep
down we all want to. We just think we're
not allowed. And when you go first in
saying the thing that everyone was
thinking, you become the instant leader.
That small social risk is actually what
makes people like you. It makes them
trust you. So if you've thought in this
video of any frames that you're stuck
in, my challenge to you today is to step
outside just one of them. And if you
want to get a full step-by-step guide to
the little actions like this that make
you magnetic in your private life, your
dating life, and work, wherever, you may
want to join our course Charisma
University.
It's a step-by-step 30-day program that
[music] tells you exactly what to do
every day so that by the end of it you
are radiating confidence and charisma
without even thinking about it. Here's
just a few things that our past members
have said. I had confidence in some
areas but not in others. Then Charisma
University changed that for me. Since
beginning the program, I have seen
noticeable changes in my life. It has
helped me unlock the confidence that
comes with knowing that I can go into
any social situation and crush it.
Another member wrote, "I've always been
bad at expressing myself in situations
that weren't one-on-one in
conversations. I'd find myself hesitant
to speak or I'd get caught in my own
head overthinking things. After SEU, I
am now way more confident in saying what
I think. I feel much happier all the
time. I was even able to talk to a woman
I've had a crush on for about a year and
made a great first impression. Overall,
I love this course and I keep going back
to it when I need a refresher on the
daily action modules. This program is
literally guaranteed to change your
life, which means that you can take the
entire course and if you don't think
it's worth every penny, you can give
yourself a full refund right from inside
the program. So, if you want to see if
this course is right for you, click the
link on the screen now or in the
description below. Either way, I hope
that you've enjoyed today's video and I
hope to see you in the next one.